[Music]
this time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'll see you
soon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
friends
[Music]
anymore
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
parks and movies
[Music]
I'm hungry
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Jesus Christ
[Music]
[Music]
here
[Music]
please
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let us pray
evolution
press the questions
too
oh God who in your wondrous Providence
chose your servant Benedict to preside
over your church and we pray that having
served as the vicar of your son on Earth
he may be welcomed by him into eternal
glory who lives and reigns with you in
the unity of the Holy Spirit one God
forever and ever
our first reading today will be
proclaimed in Spanish the readings
chosen from among those
for funeral liturgies
from the book of the prophet Isaiah
senor
is
the Potter no better than the clay
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Lord is my shepherd there is nothing I
shall want
Psalm 20 22 which will be conserial
psalm
s
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh God
[Music]
foreign
please
foreign
[Music]
give him
because
[Music]
foreign
thank you Dominique
foreign
[Music]
from the first letter of Saint Peter
blessed be God the father of our Lord
Jesus Christ
who in his great Mercy has given us a
new birth as his sons
by raising Jesus Christ from the dead
so that we have a sure hope and the
promise of an inheritance
that can never be spoiled
or soiled and Never Fade Away
because it is being kept for you in the
heavens
through your faith
God's power will guard you until the
Salvation which has been prepared
is revealed at the end of time
this is a cause of great joy for you
even though you may for a short time
have to bear being plagued by all sorts
of Trials
so that when Jesus Christ is revealed
your faith will have been tested and
proved like gold
only it is more precious than gold
which is corruptable even though it
Bears testing by fire
and then you will have praise and glory
and honor
you did not see him
yet you love him
and still without seeing him
you are already filled with a joy
So Glorious that it cannot be described
because you believe
and you are sure of the end to which
your faith looks forward
that is
the salvation of your souls
verbum dominios
[Music]
the Hallelujah verses take in front of
the Gospel of Saint John chapter 6 verse
40.
as my father's will that whoever sees
the son and believes in him shall have
eternal life
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the gospel is taken from the gospel of
Saint Luke chapter 23 verses 39 through
46.
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
are you not the Christ he said save
yourself and us as well
but the others spoke up and rebuked him
have you no fear of God at all he asked
you got the same sentence as he did but
in our case we deserved it we are paying
for what we did but this man has done
nothing wrong
Jesus he said remember me when you come
into your kingdom indeed I promise you
he replied today you will be with me in
Paradise
it was now about the sixth hour and with
the Sun eclipsed a Darkness came over
the whole land until the ninth hour
the veil of the temple was torn right
down the middle and when Jesus had cried
out in a loud voice he said father into
your hands I commit my spirit
these words he breathed his last
and we prepare ourselves now to hear the
homily Pope Francis will deliver
on this occasion when we celebrate the
solemn requiemas
for Pope Benedict the 16th the person he
called a great master of catechesis
into your hands I commend my spirit
these were the final words
his last breath as it were which summed
up what he what had been his entire life
ceaseless
self-entrustment into the hands of his
father
hands of forgiveness and compassion
healing and mercy
benedictions
which led him also to entrust himself
into the hands of his brothers and
sisters
by the father's will he shouldered all
the consequences and hardships entailed
by the gospel even to seeing his hands
pierced for love see my hands he says to
Thomas and to each of us
pierced hands that constantly reach out
to us inviting us to recognize the love
that God has for us and to believe in it
by the little money concerned me a
spirit
into your house
and give me yours elves
foreign
[Music]
the nourishment of God's truth of God's
word
of his presence
foreign
with the oil
gospel that he spread and testified to
for his entire life
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign Pope Francis concluded his
homily Benedict faithful friend of the
bridegroom
may your joy be complete as you hear his
voice
now and forever
and we Applause briefly in silence to
reflect upon
the words of scripture and the words of
our Holy Father Pope Francis
foreign
worthy of note the homily we just heard
contained a number of citations directly
from Pope Benedict
from his encyclical Deus karitas EST
the Chrismas homily he gave in 2006
and the homily for the beginning
of his pontificate in 2005.
we now move to the prayer of the
faithful
foreign
[Music]
Benedict
who has fallen asleep
[Music]
we pray in French
Francois
[Music]
Christ's victory over evil and death
[Music]
we pray in Arabic
foreign
foreign
[Music]
we pray in Portuguese
our brothers and sisters
and
for the least of our brothers and
sisters
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Benedict
ions
and we now transition to the Liturgy of
the Eucharist
the choir will offer as our operatory
chant Domine Jesus Christi
and as we move forward we reflect on
these words Pope Francis said yesterday
Pope Benedict's acute and gentle thought
was not self self-referential but
ecclesial
as he always wanted to accompany us in
in our encounter with Jesus
Jesus crucified and risen the living one
and the Lord was the destination to
which Pope Benedict led us taking us by
the hand
may he help us ReDiscover in Christ The
Joy of believing and the hope of living
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Giovanni Bautista Ray our celebrant at
the altar has offered the gifts that he
can now
in sensing the faithful
the today's liturgy based largely on the
right of Christian burial of a supreme
pontiff there have been several
modifications
numerals
Domino's
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the Eucharistic prayers
[Music]
universe
mysterious
[Music]
benediction phrase it is
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Maria
cumbiato Joseph
sponsor
um
gloriosis
consent is
foreign
[Music]
nearest
Papa nostro Francesco
map is
acquisition is
what is Julio's familiar quantity
against
omnis Williams
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
better Christian dominant nostrum
[Music]
is
[Music]
Gloria
room
[Music]
s institutions
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Christine
[Music]
Domino's
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
of peace
foreign
[Music]
Jesus
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this community
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Lord Jesus
[Music]
Christ
[Music]
[Music]
Is Us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
days
[Music]
stories
[Music]
followers
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the Lord
[Music]
spirit of God
[Music]
[Music]
us
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
it is
[Music]
[Music]
I'll be used
[Music]
to see
[Music]
you'll save them
[Music]
praise
[Music]
Jesus
[Music]
as the choir has chanted the penitential
Psalm 130 out of the depths I Cry To You
O Lord about 50
000 of our brothers and sisters here
have been receiving Christ
the Lord of Glory
it is our meeting with him that we
prepare ourselves for as the catechism
says for the Christian the day of death
inaugurates at the end of our
sacramental life the Fulfillment of what
has been begun in baptism
and we see a symbol of baptism one of
these symbols on Pope Benedict's coat of
arms that we've been seeing on his
coffin
the shell
along with a symbol of his Earthly life
a symbol of the the Mora highly symbolic
heraldic symbol from Bavaria
as well as the the bear a symbol of the
ecclesial offices that Pope Benedict
held during his life
as we know baptism the the day on which
we are invited to conform ourselves to
the image of Christ
which is then we are then helped to do
through the other sacraments
through the Sacrament of Confirmation
anointing that we receive
always an invitation to participate in
the Feast of the Kingdom anticipated
here in this Sacrament we participate in
now that of Eucharist
it is the church our mother who always
Bears Us in her womb nourishing us on
these sacraments during our Earthly
pilgrimage
in which we are accompanied
to the very end so that we may surrender
ourselves as we heard in the homily
today into the father's hands we now
prepare to conclude this Requiem Mass
for Pope Benedict
the closest community in prayer Williams
questions
as we receive sacred sustenance from
your church oh Lord we pray that your
servant Benedict who is the faithful
Steward of your mysteries on Earth May
Praise Your Mercy forever
and console Church on her pilgrimage
through history as she awaits the Lord's
return
[Music]
reminding us that
I was baptized members of Christ will
share in his very own life as well as
the blessing of water and reminder of
our baptism
[Music]
please
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
of the Divine Mysteries
[Music]
forever and ever amen
purpose
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
May the angels lead you into Paradise
May the martyrs come and welcome you and
take you into the holy city the new and
eternal Jerusalem
make wires of angels welcome you and
with Lazarus who is poor no longer may
you have
Eternal rest
concludes
the pallbearers approach in the
coffin of
the pope emeritus
Benedict
they will bear his coffin
into the Basilica
and then to his final resting place
below the Basilica in
the Vatican grottos
[Music]
it is
[Music]
resorts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
every river
[Music]
pray your God
[Music]
as him who is
[Music]
the last chant here the
Canticle of canticles you might say that
our lady
sang out
on her visitation to her cousin
Elizabeth
Canticle used
every evening
fitting that our lady would have the
final word here
[Music]
bearish race
coffin bearing the north remains of
Meritus
Isabelle's totally connected
[Music]
as you mentioned at the beginning of the
broadcast we will be brought into the
Basilica
there will be a
private ceremony later on
for those who watch on television you
saw and you can see the Cypress coffin
that the
father's remains are in
that will be sealed
sink coffin
which will in turn
s
the final coffin in
[Music]
that's there's a
closet liturgical ceremony that goes
along with that
at that point the body will be taken
into the grottos beneath the Vatican
basilica
where there are yet in a few more
prayers for the final
of our Holy Father who replaced in the
chapel where John Paul II Saint John
Paul II his predecessor was originally
buried priorities beatification
and that is in accordance with the end
of the 16th of final missions
our Holy Father Pope Francis
having come down from the presider's
chair
waiting the
coffin of his predecessor
and is there to give a final blessing
and say a few words by placing his hand
upon the coffin and bounding his head in
prayer and recollection
As We Know on several occasions Pope
Francis has said that he used to visit
Benedict often
has called him a
[Music]
good on the most in a recent interview
actually did not hesitate to call
Benedict descent
or some of his own fellow countrymen
to bid
their Pope Benedict farewell
[Music]
he called those meetings with the Pope
and Meredith Benedict personal fraternal
and
final farewell between
Francis
who accompanied his pontificate
[Music]
image of his coffin being born into
Saint Peter's Basilica we bring this
live broadcast of the celebration of the
solemn Requiem Mass for Pope Emeritus
Benedict XVI to a close
will return tomorrow morning for the
Liturgy for the solemn
solemnity of epiphany that begins about
10 a.m Rome time
on behalf of Vatican media a warm thank
you to all of our Media Partners
Catholic TV Catholic faith Network
Shalom word television networks USA
EWTN Salt and Light media Shalom TV
India Sunday Shalom at madarashan TV CBS
Radio CBS News in London
Sirius XM radio the Catholic channel
relevant radio radio Maria in England
Papua New Guinea Lithuania and luminous
radio
special thanks today to our coordinator
Alessandro de carterlis and Adriano
Vitalis are in studio audio technician
thanks to two of the Knights of Columbus
for their continual support for the
disaster
Communications that make these
broadcasts possible throughout all of
the years
now carry
put the 16th and our in our hearts
Christus
to be Jesus Christ
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]